you surprised a guess on the Eric Andre
show with stunts sometimes stunts that
maybe surprised or shocked me a little
bit did something to seth rogen yeah we
put his cell phone number up on the
screen and he's a little bit upset about
that it is real personal and he didn't
know you were going to do that he had no
idea he's a little bit expression that's
the expression of a guy who doesn't know
yeah you're putting his real cell phone
out yeah there's a little bit upset
about that but I think we should call
him what do you guys think yeah well I
think what's the number again put up the
number we have a phone right here
yeah hit that audiences memorize it but
I have seven six two and then five four
five mmm is that phone from 1945 sir
it's the real phone we use actually hey
SF it's Conan I'm here with Eric Andre
Andy Richter we just wanted to say hi
we're calling you from the show and we
just wanted to say hello hope you're
doing well and I'm guessing I'm told
this is your number so god bless
give me buzz I still haven't heard back
about neighbors one if I'm in that
give me a little bus we'll find out wait
what's that he called back okay dad
hello guys quit giving out my number
okay you treated a nightmare for me ruin
my life I've had to get a new phone
number just stop it okay well that's
sorry about that says how do we reach
you then in the future it's three two
three eight three four two oh seven nine
Oh
[Applause]